this was a very very good result for the  labor party because what was clear was  there was a choice the labor party has  been putting forward a positive plan for  the future how we stabilize and grow our  economy so we were putting a positive  choice to the electorate in Chester the  government is worn out tired has crashed  the economy and the verdict was very  very clearly given and I think that's a  clear message to the Prime Minister  Rishi sunak but people are fed up and  they want to change and there's this  strong sense now the government has run  out of Road run out of ideas hasn't got  a mandate and it's time for change